So let's see an example of
when does it really matter.
Let's look at the multiprocessor
that has coherent memory but
out of order cores.
And specifically the core
can predict the branch and
later verify that it was taken or
not taken correctly.
The store instructions in each core
are done strictly in program order, so
it doesn't reorder any stores.
But the loads between store instructions
can be reordered on a core.
Now let's say that we have CORE 1 and
CORE 2 where CORE 1 executes
the following code while a flag is zero,
it waits, and then it prints the data.
While CORE 2 writes ten to data,
then increments
data by five then sets the flag and
let's say that both flag and
data are zero initially before
CORE 2 gets to change them.
So now CORE 1 when it prints the data,
what are the values that
it can possibly print?
Can it print zero?
Can it print five?
Can it print ten?
Can it print 15, and
can it print anything else?